So I'm going to give a talk today about probably 45 minutes,
15 minutes.
I'll talk about the future.
Where are we headed?
Technologies.
I'll talk about different aspects of innovation and as well I'll finish it up
with my personal perspectives on innovation.
What I've gained from my personal experience working about 20 years in different
organizations that NASA,
so starting with the population,
if you look at the population of the earth from the beginning of the evolution
of the modern human,
about 200,000 years ago until the year 1800,
it's fascinating that we only have a population of less than 1,000,000,200
years.
We went from less than 1 billion to about seven and a half billion people.
And that trend will keep increasing as we reached to 2050 to reach about 10
billion people.
And that is fascinating growth.
Even though there is some continent,
the growth is stagnant or not,
or decreasing it.
Like in Europe,
it's expected that the African continent is going to contribute significantly to
their population growth in the world.
Uh,
something interesting is at the same time we have that the exponential growth of
technology is something that we've never ever seen before.
If you look at the computational power that's expected in the next 30,
40,
50 years,
so in the year 20,
35 approximately,
we expect the computational power is going to be equivalent to one human brain.
And if we keep extrapolating that by the year 20,
65,
20,
70,
or humanities brains will be able to be put in a single computational power.
Now imagine the possibilities of that.
Imagine having a small lab lab,
a small iPhone in your pocket and being so powerful that he can do so many
things.
Now that there's a concern though,
because you know,
we're talking about huge population growth,
huge expression of technology that's going to be able to have big impact on,
on the job market.
So,
so experts will typically tell you that where is there when there is a new
technology that typically creates jobs?
And that is exactly correct.
No question.
But the problem is we're talking about different things here.
We're talking about artificial intelligence and advanced robotics.
So we can,
we combine these two things.
It's a very powerful thing.
It's almost like you're creating almost new species.
So imagine a humanoid robot with the computational power of billions of people
being able to think about things a human will never be able to do.
And how does it fit into the,
into,
into the world,
into the life,
into the economy.
So that's going to be very challenging.
And um,
so this is a very controversial topic.
If you,
if you talk to all the scientists,
researchers,
they will tell you I almost,
almost 50,
50 distribution,
50 will tell you,
no,
this is going to be good.
It's going to be creating more jobs and 50 are very,
very concerned.
Actually.
They tell you this is going to have fundamental impacts on the way we live and
economies and jobs and,
and,
and everything else.
I think even they caught him.
He is,
will probably look different than in the future.
So if you have huge amount of,
of people without a job and a lot of the things are being automated,
that's going to be big,
big impact.
So it's not going to happen.
Suddenly.
Obviously it's going to be a transition.
And I can tell you from our personal experience in the mission control at NASA,
we had initially when they had the polar program,
we had back rooms with hundreds of people supporting people in the front room.
And um,
as we kept advancing,
we went to the shadow where the computational systems became a little bit more
advanced.
And,
um,
and basically we didn't need that many people.
And now with the new ones,
the net new generations for the future was getting less and less and less so.
So it will be transitioned.
So jobs will not be requiring as many people to do them,
but at the end there's going to be a significant impact.
I have a lot of doctor friends,
I always joke with them.
So look at it at an example of how the power of these artificial intelligence
systems will be in the market.
So if you are a primary care physician and um,
and you,
you have a patient,
the patient will tell you what the symptoms are.
You'll base take what you've learned,
you experience what you know from medical school and you'll try to do a
diagnosis.
And often there's percentages that there is misdiagnosis.
So on the other hand,
look at an opportunity where you talked to two system that has access to every
single medical research paper ever published,
every single analysis from or case studies from,
from hospitals,
every single book.
And not only that,
it can actually gather all this information and big data and be able to find
trends and,
and,
and diagnosis that nobody will ever be able to do a new human being will be able
to do.
So look at the power.
So how is primary care physician be able to compete with something like that?
And the same thing with lawyers.
The same thing with engineers.
Same thing with pilots.
We can can go on,
on and on.
Sometimes we have talks about,
you know,
argue about what job is going to be difficult to replace.
And obviously there is a lot of jobs will be difficult to replace.
Bye Bye bye automations and intelligence systems.
But the t is,
it's going to be a significant impact.
We're not saying that the future is going to be all robots and nothing else,
but what we're saying is there's definitely something to think about because
it's going of becoming soon.
I was going to have tremendous impacts on all of us.
So the thing is we need to be able to tackle these problems or,
or this upcoming technology.
We need to start thinking about it from today.
We need to engage academic institutions,
we need to engage government,
industry,
everybody working together.
Um,
and that's the only way that we are able to tackle everything and advanced,
uh,
talking about,
um,
uh,
technologies and um,
and the gap between what academia is producing at what the government that,
what industry,
there is a lot of disconnect between the is produced and then what's being used.
Eh,
do you have a lot of corporations,
for example,
that their produce technologies and,
and did you have patterns and then they put them on the side?
Same thing with academia.
You can go to any academic institutions and talk to the technology transfer
office and you see hundreds of Ip and patents nobody is willing to use because
they have no use for it.
So I believe before you do something and invest in developing a new technology,
you have to be aligned with who is going to be a customer before you invest in
it.
So by the time you have this achieved and completed,
there is the line that's kind of take it,
create a new industry and new business.
Uh,
and,
and that's how we going bridge the gap and capitalized on the technologies and
does it research and development.
Not only for the sake of just putting it in portfolios,
but make sure it's being used and we capitalize on it as much as possible.
Yeah.
So let me give you a quick example of why we are interested in innovation at
NASA.
So recently then the last few years we retired the special program and the
intention from the space shuttle program was to build the space station.
The space station is a national international lab and we're learning so much
every single day.
About the behavior of the human body and in the space,
in microgravity environment,
we're learning about the long term effects on humans from that radiation,
gravity environment and so on.
Obviously there's big effects on that in the muscles,
on the bones,
on the vision,
on the psychology.
So when we send somebody to,
to,
to deep space exploration,
we need to understand these things cause in space station,
if there's any problem,
any issues,
obviously we can bring them back fast.
But when you're talking about sending somebody to Mars,
which admission could take six to eight months to a year depending on what,
what,
what the way you go in there.
It's a big problem.
It's a big,
big issue.
So many of them to stand a lot of these issues before we invest in and commit to
sending a person,
uh,
recruit to two different planets.
So right now that the three options that initially we had was going to the moon
again and establishing a permanent base.
I'm going to an asteroid or going to Mars.
And recently it seems the emphasis is headed toward going to Mars and that's
where we are going to be going.
So by doing that,
uh,
obviously there's significant challenges,
a lot of issues we're going to be facing.
So we're going to be creative as much as possible because the limitations and
funding and technology,
either we have become creative,
innovative,
and we think out of the box or everything will be much more complicated to
solve.
And the,
if you notice now we have a lot of new commercial,
new space emerging and they're working in the lower earth orbit,
what we call their earth orbit.
Uh,
after we finished that,
now we'll concentrate and going deep and we're establishing them that market to
the,
to,
to the commercial.
Uh,
think if you look at the,
uh,
at what NASA is contribution and the government's contribution,
creating jobs and creating innovation as well.
We,
early on in the century,
we heavily in creating,
uh,
the basic research for aeronautics.
And that resulted in salvaging companies like Boeing,
Lockheed,
and so on that that are creating significant amount of jobs and at huge,
uh,
gross domestic project product.
The same thing we're doing right now,
like I said with the commercial is
developing technology and giving everything and enabling the commercial entities
to work in the low earth orbit is that by the year 2014,
it was approximately $330 billion,
um,
uh,
worthwhile.
And that trend,
obviously we'll keep increasing and we'll,
we'll,
we'll talk about some other stuff in terms of miniaturization and how it's
impacting technology,
making it better and more effective and so on.
So,
uh,
what are the main technologies that will be mainstream in the next 10 years,
let's say approximately.
So big data obviously is going to be an one of them,
a big data internet of things.
Now the thing is big data is nothing without having a system that can go through
it and be able to decipher the big data and make something meaningful out of
that information that you have.
Otherwise,
just junk data.
This,
it's worthless.
Look at medical records,
if you can have a millions of people's medical records and go through them.
And I'm sure there are trends that currently we don't understand,
but there is actually correlations between certain things.
So they will be able to do diagnosis or premed prevent disease before they
happen.
And even when they happen,
there'll be able to find ways how to be able to solve in much more effective way
by,
by the suffering millions and billions of data points because we have such
strong and robust,
uh,
artificial intelligence systems,
driverless cars.
So I got familiar with the driverless cars when I was at ames.
You see the little Google cars driving by all the time.
It's kind of fascinating.
And,
um,
I think that's fine by itself could have huge impacts on the market.
So if you look,
what are the benefits from having driverless cars?
So you will have zero accidents.
That's the point.
Obviously.
Um,
initially the way we do it is we need to do more cases.
So the more information we have,
the algorithms becomes refined and,
and that's when you become getting better and better.
So the more cars we have,
the more we drive,
the better the algorithms and,
and,
and everything is working properly.
So imagine having a car with no accident because most of the time accidents are
human based.
So if we can prevent that,
that's going to be a big advantage.
Another thing is becoming productivity.
Look how much productivity we are wasting by driving.
And some people,
especially in the states,
they have to commute for hours.
And so it's,
it's,
it's completely wasted productivity traffic.
There will be no traffic anymore.
First of all will be significantly less cars.
Second cars will be able to communicate with each other so you can drive faster,
close to each other.
And,
and so we'll let you go much faster without creating congestions and highways
that we typically see every now and then.
Air Pollution,
they won't be money pollution,
psychological effects and people like,
um,
when people,
each certain ages they won't be able to drive anymore.
And that causes huge impacts.
I've seen it from my,
my brother,
my,
my father in law when he got 80,
he got his driver's license taken and you can see a big impact on people.
So all that stuff will be something of the past.
Now the thing is,
uh,
how,
what,
how is that going to disrupt the industry?
So typically we,
if you look at an average house in the states,
we have two to three cars per per house.
And there's absolutely no need to have more than one car.
Even having several cars for that,
for the neighborhood.
That's what the trend is going to be headed for.
So you're not,
you're not going to be able to manufacture as many cars cause there no need for
money,
cars,
insurance companies,
two things.
First of all,
they don't have as many cars to,
to ensure the second wide.
Would you insure a car if there zero accidents,
right?
So,
so need to be thinking about these kind of things.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
manufacturers,
maintenance,
facilities,
oil and gas.
Imagine how much oil and gas we consume.
So it will be a signal.
Imagine if you reduce it by a fraction,
the amount of cars,
and then obviously as all of us see,
not only,
it's got to be much less cars,
but it will,
we we're headed toward electricity and maybe solar and renewable energy.
So how are the all the senses you going to be impacted?
I think they need to start sitting together and brainstorming,
strategizing about the future because this is coming.
There's no question.
It just a matter of time.
So if you work on it from today,
you'll have much better impact and be able to,
to position yourself in the market.
Miniaturization,
look at this interesting thing in 1956.
That's five megabytes.
And I look at what we have today and keep going on that trend.
I can't even imagine how,
what's going to happen,
you know,
so,
so in terms of medicalization,
um,
the last 25 years,
people that needed satellite,
a satellite used to cost maybe a hundred,
150 to a hundred depending on what it is.
And the average age also as of service used to be tens of years and the decades.
And,
uh,
the thing now is that that will change the market is we have many
generalizations.
So a lot of these big components,
we can put them significantly smaller.
And then the technology is changing at such a pace that if you send something
and you want to work for 20 years,
the first,
first five years going to be obsolete because technology is already overcome it.
So by having,
for example,
the satellite business,
if you have macro cubes that you send them the last about a year and a and then
they come down.
So it's an opportunity for you to,
to keep replenishing it with the,
with the state of the art technology.
And then access to space is getting space,
getting much cheaper.
That is not a prime to keep replenishing it.
So it's not a cost inhibitor.
Uh,
it used to be $10,000 per pound,
$1,000 per pound.
We're getting $200 per pound.
And now there are companies,
commercial companies,
for example,
there's one in New Zealand called a rocket labs.
They're developing robots may,
I'm sorry,
a rocket made from composite and uh,
they're supposed to get the price of pound to orbit about $10 a soldier so he
can see,
you can see the trend.
So that by itself is going to open huge amount of markets and Google actually
was in,
you guys were involved in some satellite,
the things and the Silicon Valley augmented reality.
That's something of importance of significance,
importance,
uh,
not only augmented reality but also in terms of virtual reality.
But wearing the glasses example,
we'll look at them in them and space station or even go into two different
places where you kind of mission control can see exactly what you're looking at.
You can give you instructions on the screen.
And I know Google came with the Google glasses and we did some,
some work with them too in terms of partnerships,
experiments,
some how can be used,
uh,
stuff like that.
And I'm in the medical field can,
can have significant impacts.
And then we're talking about virtual reality is going to be super mature.
It's going to impact several sectors.
Even the tourism sector will be,
will be part of that.
So these are things that I'm going to be so common as we move forward.
Autonomous flying vehicles.
I mean who,
who,
who heard about that 20 years ago and now it's like almost everybody can have
small,
uh,
android all the UAV.
And um,
it's,
the good thing about them is they're establishing to a new market.
So the key is we're talking about so many technologies here,
but the key is how do you develop service industries to align with those?
So the Internet,
when it came,
it was a technology and look at what industry has created because of technology
that it was the foundation.
So same thing with this,
with all these technologies and even other technologies as well,
we know they're going to be there.
We know we're going to be mainstream.
How it can you align your business models to create services that will service
all these industries.
That is the key here.
A three d manufacturing,
the question is,
is is going to be something of significant importance for us.
If we go to Mars for example,
there is no point of getting so many spare parts with that cause it's very heavy
and we don't know what's going to fail.
We don't know who's taking the spare part and with actually use it.
So it makes perfect sense just to have a three d printing machine and the
whenever you need something and they beam the foul and you print it there and
not only you can print it,
but we can use a soil.
We'll be doing some analysis and research using the soul,
a soil of Mars to create actually this feedstock to create these components.
So it will be very,
very effective and very efficient.
And another thing also is when you create very intricate parts,
when you have a launch environment,
sometimes very difficult to get these things in tacked onto orbit.
So you'll be able to manufacture a lot of the stuff and in space.
And then it has,
you can look at medical industry,
look into Oregon reproduction with the three d machines.
You can look into food industry,
they're even talking about apparel as well.
Shirts,
you can,
you can start printing shirts in the future.
There's some people say that and they're distant future.
You'll be able to download a file for the share that you want and you will be
able to print it in a facility and we access to immediately to it.
Now the thing is,
we talked about a lot,
a lot of technologies,
but again,
there is a big,
big thing.
It's cybersecurity.
If you don't have a robust cybersecurity,
then it's gotta be difficult to have effectiveness and everything.
We just,
we just discussed driverless cars,
for example.
You're driving to work or the car's technique to work,
somebody hacks into it and takes it.
So these things are,
are going to happen.
And unfortunately it's,
um,
it's,
it's a risk.
So cybersecurity is very,
very essential that we understand how to,
how to help to build robust systems.
We'll be able to,
and capable of defending and making sure everything is safe.
Um,
I'll give a couple of examples about some disruptive industries.
So the first one I'll talk about Zara.
Zara's.
Um,
it's a clothing store and right now we have,
they have about 2000 stores worldwide.
And when they started,
people have serious doubts.
It will be successful.
It's a very competitive industry and I'm getting into it.
It's almost unheard of.
So what these people did,
they found a gap.
There's always a gap and Annie Business.
So the thing is,
if you are successful filling the gap,
it will be successful.
The key is finding what is the gap and do a flawless execution.
So what these people did,
uh,
when,
when you,
when you go to a store and you see a clothing garment,
it takes about a year from the time designers put it together until it hits the
shelves in stores,
it's about 12 months.
So what what Zara did is they reduce that time for two weeks.
So a designer can,
can draw something until it hits the shelf.
It only takes about two weeks.
And then what they did is also the create sense of scarcity.
So they create only very limited amount of,
uh,
of shirts or pants or dresses and whatever that they're sold out.
That's it.
They're not going to do them again.
So you're feeling that you're buying a shirt man year.
It's very unique.
It's very skirt.
A lot of people have access to it and um,
and not only that,
if you walk to any of the stores,
they have managers with their laptop or their iPad and take a dose talking to
customers and taking notes.
Okay.
What do you like about this shirt?
Do you like anything different about it?
I mean,
would it make sense if this was like this or like that?
And they send all that information into the headquarters and they have analysis
of the,
of what the customers want and to see big area that people are interested in.
Well guess what,
two weeks later they have the shirt with all this input that people had and they
keep doing this iteration over and over and,
and,
and they becoming so successful.
I mean,
I'm surprised almost everywhere I go.
I see that company before,
I only used to see it in Spain when I used to spend,
I used to,
I like this.
They had very nice design.
They used to buy stuff there.
But now you can see it anywhere.
Even in Asia,
in Europe and United States.
I mean everywhere they have stores and very,
very successful.
The owner actually is one of the richest guys in the world right now.
Netflix.
So everybody obviously knows Netflix.
But I want to highlight how finding successful business model,
it's not enough.
You have to keep innovating and moving forward and adapting.
So,
um,
at that time when,
when the,
when that floods came and initially people were having issues going to
Blacksburg,
I used to hate it,
get,
I love movies,
but he used to hate going to blockbuster,
renting it because I never had time to go and return it in time.
Almost every single time.
It cost me about 10,
$15 just to rent the movie.
And it became very annoying.
So when the technology changed from VHS to DVD,
then Netflix came in with a,
with a brilliant distribution scheme and they put it in major cities.
So you will,
you were able to get a DVD and one or two days maximum and they change the model
from going to rent to subscription model.
So,
so people were subscribed to the surface and we're able to get one or two DVDs
per month or I'm getting access to that.
So after they did this,
they,
they became extremely successful and even offered to,
to,
to sell themselves to blockbuster.
Blockbuster didn't see the values.
They continued on their own and eventually ended up failing.
But what happened with,
with this,
they weren't satisfied.
So when the technology became mature enough that the Internet became fast and
broadband,
they started streaming the movies.
People get anxious.
You know,
they don't,
the patients goes down and down.
The more technology we have,
people don't want to wait one or two days.
They want it.
Right now I'm getting at,
I had to get access immediately to it.
So they started the biggest streaming libraries available in the market and it
became extremely,
extremely successful.
Again,
did not satisfy,
they were not satisfied cause that's a,
that's an area other people can come into it and take advantage of it and be the
intent of market.
So they went actually into the production.
So it became a production company.
And from the production company,
they became like that.
A very successful company.
Look at the,
at the,
uh,
the smartphone companies.
How much impact did it have?
The GPS and radio and the camera and music gaming serving a big,
big impact on a lot of aspects actually.
And that's very,
very essential.
That tells you you have to be looking at a small company that had,
have a big impact on what you're doing.
Um,
if you,
if you look at the startups,
sometimes a lot of these,
uh,
activities come from,
from garages.
People work in a small garage and you have to look into,
into,
to what's going on because that's where most of the ideas will come from.
Okay.
I'll give you a couple examples about how to become creative basically.
So there was a city in Europe that people were having problems with,
posters having posters there and um,
and it was ruining a lot of the architecture that we're having.
And uh,
so they thought about having,
how can we use that so that they talked to the city and they met several times.
They were having issues with that.
So they started putting posters with the stamp,
with dates saying,
okay,
well this is a,
this is putting it a date thing.
Okay,
they change or a template,
it's been canceled.
And that made it start making some,
some differences with what they tried to do.
Uh,
there's also a speeding ticket program,
Eh,
there is a small town in Europe.
They were having a lot of issues with the speeding cars.
So one of the people came up with a brilliant idea.
They said,
well,
what if we actually implement the program where we give some of the benefits to
the people that are not speeding?
So they put cameras in these towns and the cameras capture this,
the car that we're speeding as a car that would not speeding and the cards would
not speeding.
We're actually being put on the side.
And they developed a model where 70% of the proceeds go to the,
to that,
to the city,
and 30% of the proceeds go to the people that would not speeding.
So you're rewarding the people that are not speeding at the same time.
You're getting value because you're still making 70% profit.
And that had huge,
huge impact in,
in um,
and having,
uh,
reductions in speeding cars in that specific town.
Uh,
there was a company in Holland that,
um,
that manufacturer advanced bicycles with a lot of advanced electronics and they
were having a lot of problems in shipping.
We're a lot of it,
we're getting damaged.
So what they did,
what are the people came up with a brilliant idea saying once we package it,
like it looks like a TV.
And then by doing that,
just simple as that.
There are 70 to 80% reduction in the amount of damage as people were having.
But so that tells you the amount of creativity.
So a lot of innovation actually is derived from nature at,
um,
it's interesting how nature actually is very innovative in sense,
right?
So it's a lot of things can be a drag from there.
So about a couple of years ago I was in Japan and uh,
went to the professor to a,
in one of the weekends to a Lotus farm land that I was in us.
I looked at that as a man that's kind of interesting.
Look at that.
The water never sticks to that,
to the plan,
keeps going back and forth.
And then he told me a story that,
uh,
some of the Japanese scientist actually investigated the leafs and the macro
structure and develop the lead for the yogurt containers that a,
the August never sticks to it.
And that tells,
you know,
just looking at something in nature,
how you adapted and you move it forward.
Uh,
the same thing with the underwater turbans.
So,
uh,
that's a way to generate electricity from a underwater currents and there is a
lot of drag and they weren't as effective.
So they did an analysis of the world,
the fence at the Norris,
these ridges and the fence,
they create significantly less drag and they're much more effective.
So this,
they put,
uh,
this area into,
into the analysis and design and they come up new fans that looked like this and
they were significantly more effective than conventional fund that they had
before.
So I'll tell you now about some cross industry innovation.
How combining in innovation in different industries,
you create something very meaningful.
So in Africa,
some of the poor countries,
they were getting gifts and grants as an incubator for four babies.
The problem was is whenever you have them it failure and you need to have
replacement of component.
They didn't have access to that.
So as soon as they had that,
they used to put on the side and storage and that's it.
They had no use for it.
So then they started thinking about,
okay,
how can we solve that problem?
So they had teams of people,
Eh,
consultants,
they investigate what's going on.
And they found out that one of the Tiara four wheeled cars is very popular in
this region.
So they came together and said,
well,
what if we create something that we can leverage on the parts from this car to,
to,
to be able to replace any components from,
uh,
from the incubator.
And they came actually with,
with one very interesting design that can completely be replaced with parts from
the car.
And that's sort of the problem and created much,
much more value.
Now that's a fascinating story.
So this is the car mechanic from Argentina.
So if you think a car mechanic,
you know,
okay,
let's see how it goes.
Um,
they were,
they were in dinner one day having a wine,
drinking wine and I guess they were drinking so much wine that,
you know,
one of the guys just messed up and put the cork inside the bottle.
And then the started betting,
how can we get the cork out of the bottle without breaking the bottle itself?
And they started having different methods and nobody was successful and this guy
came in,
put a plastic bag.
I tried to twist it across the court,
inflated it,
and get the cork out without a problem.
Then the fascinating thing is how about that?
That's an excellent example of Bacardi.
Think outside,
you know,
take it one step further.
He had the gynecology friend,
he was a good friends with him,
so he started talking to him about,
look what I found.
Is there any,
any way we can,
we can actually use that in real life.
How can we use in delivery?
So guess what?
They came up with a system that actually extremely cheap to deliver babies and
poor countries where they don't have access to more sophisticated equipment.
And by doing that,
you see from a party to a court to,
to finding something that can save thousands and tens of thousands of people's
lives and developing country.
And,
and that's extremely low cost by just thinking completely out of the box.
So dice and actually,
um,
came to solve a big problem.
Uh,
the thing with,
with,
with vacuum cleaners,
the minute you start cleaning,
the filter gets clogged almost immediately.
And the more club you have,
the more dust than the less effective it has in the suction capabilities.
So Dyson came in the late seventies and started looking about how can I solve
this problem?
So look,
he looked into the saw mill and he starts Samil actually I would,
evolution of the air,
the dust falls down and then it goes from a different conduct.
And,
um,
and that's an example of how you can solve problems from looking at different
industries.
But also it's an excellent example of resistance.
So that was in 1979 created almost 5,000 prototypes until he found the perfect
model.
So it tells you you have to be persistent,
you have to look outside,
you have to look into other other venues together is what gives you actually
success.
And that's exactly what he did.
He became extremely successful there.
Their revenues getting close to a billion dollars actually it's,
it's an amazing company.
It's one of the best vacuums you can see.
And by the way,
I don't have stock in Dyson,
so,
so combining innovations,
um,
I'll just give you a call.
So quickly example,
it's a,
the easiest form of finding new innovative ideas by having two innovations and
combining them into one.
So the first one is I'm the cook,
the bottles and the cans and then they have a new new designs.
Actually it's combined both of them.
It's a,
it's a can and I'm sorry that the cap and you open it.
Like if,
if it was a can,
it's kind of very unique.
And then the cronut,
the cronut,
it's a doughnut and across on,
and I'm a key and was saying that there is a very nice a cronut place here in
Dublin.
I didn't get a chance to go see it,
but it seems like a good deal.
Um,
open innovation.
So we've been extremely successful at NASA leveraging on opening innovation.
Most of the time solutions come from completely different industries beside
yours and it's,
it's very important that you take advantage of that.
So we look at the case study done by Harvard,
uh,
Miss Medical School,
to,
to develop an algorithm to,
to improve the,
the mega blast nucleotide sequencing.
So the first run,
they spent several years and he spent about $2 million developing this algorithm
and uh,
they got the solution and for three hours and it was actually very not very
accurate,
about 72%.
Then they hired two postdocs and the postdocs,
uh,
spent about a year,
they pay them $120,000 and they were able to reduce the time from 4.3 hours to
47 minutes.
And the accuracy went up from 72 to 77 and then they took advantage of the open
innovation platforms and the port in the market.
And by doing that they were able to reduce the time from 4.3 hours to 16 second,
the accuracy went to 80% and the only spent $6,000 and the solutions,
uh,
this is actually the best solution.
If you look at the chart here,
all these things above the green are better solutions that the original one and
significantly cheaper.
But that tells you the power of open innovation.
And um,
there is a concern of are for people understand I'm talking to different
industries.
If you advertise you your,
your problems,
your gap,
then you're opening it to the competitor to see what's going on in your company.
So it could be a challenge and that's maybe some people haven't taken as much
advantage of that technology,
but recently they've been finding ways to,
to,
to make it anonymous and then break it down into,
into,
into component level that the whole system to break it down to component level
to solve the problem.
And then you can get solutions without knowing an advertising.
Uh,
what your issues are.
Two potential competitors in the field.
So I'll give you a quick perspectives on innovation based on what I've seen in
the past 20 years and things that worked for me.
How can we make,
um,
an environment more creative?
What roadblocks do I get?
And I'll talk about some of that stuff.
So there is um,
first of all,
people think innovation or being creative.
You are born creative and,
and that is,
that is true.
You know,
some of us are much,
much more creative than others but um,
but still I think there are tools that you can do to significantly improve your
creativity.
You can talk to people that are very creative,
engaged with them,
you can read articles,
you can see cases and you can be in an environment that's very creative and,
and eventually you will be eh,
you creativity level.
I guarantee you'll definitely is going to go up.
Um,
I've tried that myself as well.
I've noticed an improvement of getting to certain environments in terms of
innovation and also an innovation has two components.
Actually there is revolutionary and evolutionary.
So evolutionary is kind of easier to get,
but um,
but it doesn't give you as much value and then that revolutionary,
uh,
or as it's being called moonshot and the cortisone shot because it's a,
it's a,
it's a problem so difficult to solve,
but if you solve it,
it has a game changing applications.
And uh,
so there's two different ones.
The second one,
the revolutionary is very difficult,
but if you get it,
companies actually have business business products that completely have an
impact on the whole industry and it's an amazing,
amazing process.
Now,
as most of you know,
innovation is very risky.
So don't put all your eggs in one basket because you're,
it's very,
very probable that most of the innovation ideas will fail.
But you have to be,
keep doing it.
Cause definitely you'll have some success that will make some difference in your
business.
And we'll have big impact in terms of employees.
There's typically farmers and hunters,
so farmers,
they want just want to have their domain,
they want to work on it.
We didn't want anything new that you just kind of nurtures of,
of ideas and farmers they want just going back and forth,
back and forth.
They can keep them all in place.
So the challenge is how do you keep both of them together and create an
environment that uses farmers to get ideas maybe and then give them,
pass them to farmers and work together synergistically to create a very solid
group that actually can give you the best results possible.
Uh,
when you come,
um,
was sometimes too to come up with,
with ideas and you're developing solutions.
It's very,
very important that you make people feel they are part of the solution.
Um,
obviously you can direct people to do things,
but if people actually believe in what they're doing and they believe they have
direct input into what's being done,
it will go way,
way longer as opposed to just directing somebody to do something because you
feel this,
well this is part of my product.
You'll find them off and spending significant amount of times,
way beyond what they expected to do because they have passion and they felt
ownership and what's going on.
And there's a for innovation,
I'm sorry,
ideation.
It's,
it's a very important element and you guys use design thinking which innovation
ideation is part of it and it makes a big difference.
The composition of the team.
So the more diverse the team in terms of diversity of age,
technical,
uh,
cultural ages,
I mean so many aspects needs to be diverse.
The more diverse the better ideas you will get.
And,
and also people from different in the different industries than the one you're
right.
Cause that will give you a very,
very different views of what we're trying to do and then concentrate on quality
and quantity,
not quality.
So try to develop as many ideas as possible,
as fast as possible.
And don't judge any ideas because if you,
if you're in a meeting,
for example,
I'm trying to brainstorm and you keep shooting people down,
then nobody else can contribute anymore.
That the energy in the room will go down significantly and try to emphasize on
the using.
Yes.
And I like your idea and we can do that.
I think this is a good thing and we can combine it with the other person.
And so saying yes,
but you know,
cause as Esn is the key to continuing that process of creating a flawless ideas,
how many times did we feel failure is not an option.
And um,
as a matter of fact where it's completely an option and the more we fail
sometimes is that we learn so many aspects and so many benefits,
we cannot have that.
The thing is it's not an option when you have a rocket for lunch and with people
there is absolutely not an option.
But before you get there,
you have to fail.
You know,
that's how you learn.
And there were discussing earlier,
there are companies that actually have programs to reward the failures that they
had and how people were able to learn from the failures and move with a that
think,
um,
uh,
and at Google every Friday,
thank Google,
it's Friday.
You guys discuss also have some failures as well,
which is fascinating cause sometimes people only executive to only discuss ideas
our product and are successful and they barely mentioned the failures.
But that is an outstanding thing to share with people because it can show you if
this is you open this door,
there's block behind this.
So don't do that.
Go there you,
there's always a learning process.
I mean there's nothing wrong with failing unless it's uh,
it's the last thing is to do with the final product and this famous guy,
you know,
it has very interesting quote in that regard as well.
So I think this statement is probably one of the biggest killers to innovation
that I've seen.
It's,
you find it every single time.
Well I'm not interested.
This is perfect.
Why do I need to improve?
You know,
what's,
what's going on with that and to think about it.
I mean we could with had been riding horses now to work instead of cars,
you know,
cause you find something that works doesn't mean that's going to be working
together forever.
You kept,
you need to keep improving,
make it,
modifying it,
make it better.
And we,
we,
we give the example of Netflix and that's a small example.
There is thousand of examples like that you always need to be keep modifying,
increasing cause otherwise somebody else who's going to come and take your place
and [inaudible] always people creative the cannot come with up with brilliant
ideas.
So I think in my opinion this was something really embedded in the culture and
it's very,
one of the things that the very difficult to change but eventually you'll be
able to do it with it,
with enough effort.
And there was a benchmarking that I use that a lot.
I tried to go out to companies,
especially outside of the aerospace company and try to see how they do the
governance,
the business models,
how they work,
the employees,
how do they work with employees.
It's very,
very important.
And even if you,
if anybody's successful always there,
its value by talking to different people,
learning a different perspectives,
how people look into things and I guarantee you,
you will always,
always learn things.
And even the companies net three successful,
there's always benefits you can gain from them.
And together when you start collecting all this value or this information,
it gives you a better insight when you was trying to plan a strategic business
plan for the future.
So risk is very important.
I mean for us for example,
if you don't take risks,
you're not going to launch anything.
Everything is risky.
The key is taking measured risk,
right?
And they,
they ask,
I'm the president,
the CEO of BMW,
why he decided to take risk and invest in the electric cars.
And he said because doing nothing is biggest risk and we can see it's,
uh,
there was a big trend not to go into [inaudible] cars and investing early.
We'll give you definitely a significant advantage compared to investing late.
You,
you'll always have an advantage by doing that.
So I had the conference,
um,
and last September.
And um,
it's interesting quote that by the president of Toyota that he came and shared
with us and he said,
if executives say this will be a success,
it will probably fail if it don't see the value.
There's,
you know,
hope for that.
And that tells you about the disconnect sometimes between the top level
executives and the working force and the managers and the directors.
So there's definitely room for improvement.
And he was referring for,
for the Prius,
is it free,
is referring to the Prius where a lot of the executives were completely against
going with a such a product and it's turned out to be one of the best products
that you are,
has ever put together.
So that's something definitely to think about.
Yeah.
Now when it comes to protection of innovation,
most of the corporations,
whenever there's downturn profit,
one of first things,
they cut his research and development and innovation.
So the key is how can you have shelter that,
because it's true,
it's a you'll going through a downturn,
but you,
if you don't keep investing,
then when the downtown goes up,
somebody else that has been invested is already ahead of you in terms of
technology and developing products.
So even in downtimes down here,
down when,
when products are,
when the market is not good,
you need to keep continue investing in innovation,
research and development because that is definitely the future.
And some,
some organization,
the the the go way out of the way to shelter them and protect them because they
see the value in doing that.
So I go a lot to,
to the Google main campus and I have some friends there.
And it's fascinating that the environment that you encounter similar to the
environment you have here and basically talking to them,
they mentioned is you cannot force innovation,
but you can create an environment in which innovation can allow to exist,
which is exactly right.
There is no way you can force somebody to be innovative.
But if you change the culture,
if chilly environment,
the governance,
then all these kinds of things will,
will inspire people to be more creative,
more innovative,
and in and in return.
We'll make a big difference.
Now in terms of uh,
uh,
where does innovation stops?
Cause we have a lot of young people with impressive ideas.
And often you'd hear executives saying,
oh,
we need to do innovation.
We need to do all that stuff.
But uh,
where does the stop?
So if executives are interested,
if employees are bringing the ideas,
why aren't companies so innovative?
Typically stops in the middle management.
And that's because risk people are not comfortable taking risks because if you
take risks,
you're,
you might create some,
some issues for availability in the,
in the company and stuff like that.
So innovation obviously is a risky business.
There's always going to be a risk is failing and as a matter of fact,
very high risk of failing.
But if we don't do it,
like I said,
it's the,
you're not going to be able to keep making progress.
So the need to be a way that executives force a middle management and put it in
the performance evaluation that they are supposed to go out and take risk
measured risk and be able to push technology forward as much as possible.
Now in terms of,
um,
environment,
uh,
in an organization,
if you notice kids,
um,
the kids are fascinating.
They can draw something like this.
For example,
this is my daughter and um,
and she painted me like this.
My wife is kind of interesting and she was I think four at this age.
And um,
I was thinking if I took that during said,
man,
this is what is this crap,
you know,
and put it the trash.
Imagine how would have it would have affected her psychologically.
But you take that and say,
man,
this is awesome.
This is great and you should see some of the dramas he does now.
It's impressive,
very fascinating.
But you know,
you can translate that into the culture.
You have to develop an environment where nobody's ridiculed.
Every idea is a good idea.
I know obviously you can have the options to implement it or not to implement
it,
but you cannot allow a,
an environment where people are afraid or embarrassed to share ideas even if
they are weird because innovation is sometimes they came up with the weirdest
ideas and that's where the most success is actually and the best products comes
from.
So it's very,
very essential that you create the proper environment where everybody's
comfortable sharing ideas even if they're not among the mainstream
in terms of um,
the environment.
Uh,
you guys are the leaders basically in my opinion in and having an excellent
environment that creates creativity.
And I'm setting an example.
Last year we were in the company,
I was benchmarking with them and we were in a conference room and the setting
was very,
very formal that I didn't feel the flow very often,
which was very,
very rigid.
And uh,
we took a break and they had,
you know,
a nice setting,
the break area with coffees and drawing boards and then the conversation became
100% different.
It's like I'm talking to different people at different company about different
topic.
Just by changing the setting itself.
We're talking completely different than what we had before.
So what I often like to tell people is when you're trying to predict the future,
don't base it on technology we have today.
Because if you do that,
you'll be very,
very limited in what you can predict.
So what you need to do is look at what patents are being in,
what areas,
what venture capitalists are investing in,
what research papers and give you all these data points we'll give you want.
They will not give you the direction where we're getting,
but we'll give you a better,
better points in the chart to predict a trend and you'll be able to be much more
successful and establishing where the whole direction is going.
And if you invest early on,
then by the time all this technology became mainstream,
guess what?
You're going to be the top.
You gotta be the leader and,
and you get to have significantly strategic advantage compared to anybody else
in the market at that time.
So,
um,
the,
when I was the technology relationship management and um,
and doing previous roles.
So I noticed a lot of that technology and the gaps that we have,
they're very similar to other companies,
other industries.
For example,
the oil and gas in the sea.
I did,
I did a lot of work and trying to develop mutual synergistic partnerships with
products that we can use for both.
And um,
at the,
at the beginning people were having issues from both actually understanding the
value from NASA and from the oil and gas industry.
And um,
we had one time a meeting where we brought five engineers from NASA,
five engineers from,
from one of these oil and gas companies.
And it was almost like dragging them.
Nobody wants to do it.
This,
you're wasting my time.
I don't want to do it.
So we forced them,
they got their untangle.
By the time they got together,
we couldn't separate them.
I mean they have so much in common that it,
the fund,
the synergy between what they were doing and,
and,
and if you do that,
then you can develop a product with more partners.
You can use less resources,
can have better perspectives,
more ideas,
more innovation,
different from different angles and making it much faster.
So when I do that,
you know,
uh,
not necessarily you can accept it.
Don't have to be competitors,
can be somebody from different industry and solve common problems that will
make,
make big sense.
So if implement that,
I think the possibilities are endless.
We can achieve things that were never been able to achieve by ourselves.
And especially for us.
For example,
look at the space exploration.
I think eventually that's going to be an international effort with all the
international community having a goal and achieving it together.
And if we do that,
there is no limitations and we'll be able to do absolutely everything we can.
So with that,
I conclude the presentation and thanks a lot for your attention.
[inaudible]
huge thanks to Omar for talking to us today.
So we've a few minutes.
I know some of you probably have to rush off to other meetings,
but for those of you here,
we have our trusty microphone that we can throw out into the audience.
So does anyone have a question that they'd like to share that they'd like to
ask?
Please raise your hand if I can see you amidst the sea of people who are
departing their seats.
Does anyone like to ask a question?
We have one over here.
Okay.
I'm going to throw it to you
speaking to the black bit.
Yes.
There you go.
Hi.
Thank you for coming and sharing.
These are very interesting thoughts about innovation.
Um,
I was just wondering,
so you talked a lot about different types of industries and different types of
structures.
Uh,
I think some of it is a very r and D and technology based.
Yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
here we all lot also a ses teams.
Um,
so wondering how we can derive learnings from what you shared,
uh,
in terms of driving innovation for sales teams,
basically.
That's a good question.
So it doesn't have to be only technology,
right?
I mean even the governance model,
how do you iterate?
How do you interact the structure of the organization,
uh,
the environment,
like I said,
in terms of creating things,
how do you compensate people with good ideas?
How do you empower people that don't take part of the process to become,
become part of the process?
So these are elements you can apply to any other industry.
It doesn't have to be certain aerospace or technical or research and
development.
The key elements can be applied across the line and in every single thing.
And the duals find substantial value from,
from,
uh,
trying to do that.
I said benchmarking is,
is so significant that tried to do with at least once every two months tried to
visit new company,
learn from them.
And the more diverse a company,
the better it is for me because I learned new things that they didn't know
before.
And eventually you build this knowledge that you will be able to,
to apply to your organization that's going to have be much more successful.
Thanks.
I'm okay.
There's another question up there and one here as well.
Just do your best to throw those as far yesterday.
Date.
Okay.
You got it because you're closer.
Hi Omar.
Thanks for your very inspiring talk and kid you started off saying,
so in the,
in the face of automation and in the face of an industry changing environment
like um,
I was asking myself,
so what we'll be doing right when they're self driving cars and yeah,
plenty of time and perhaps not in a job.
And as you moved on talking about creativity,
design thinking m would you agree or what would you say is the role of a human
being and um,
will we be,
you know,
educating people to be creative thinkers perhaps because ultimately that's what
makes us human and that what differentiates us from artificial intelligence,
I believe.
Yeah.
Oh absolutely.
And that is the question I should,
that is the main question that we need to answer.
What is the role of people and um,
unfortunately people come touch you when you talk about this topic.
It's nothing 30.
You just the fact,
you know what that's going to have impact like this or like that.
If something is going to have an impact,
there's,
we know that for 100% and uh,
what is that all of humans?
That is something we need to have think tanks between governments,
between the industry,
between academia and think about what it's going to be roles for humans.
There's going to be,
regardless of what the automation,
what artificial intelligence environment we're going to be able to have,
we still have a structure where humans can have big impact on certain qualities
and attributes that human have.
You will never be able to two to three produce with the,
with the system at the official intelligence system.
But we need to find what those are.
How do they fit into an economy?
What did they economy going to look like?
Sometimes they even think about starting to publish a paper on the future
economies after all these things happen because these are unknowns.
I mean that is the main question and we'll never,
never going to be able to solve it unless we put big teams of people from
different diverse industries working together and,
and we'll be able to stop and get some answers to these.
Thanks.
It was a question up there behind you.
There's two of them even.
Oh,
of course.
Thank you for coming and sharing your interesting ideas.
Ah,
you're starting,
um,
the presentation with the slides about the future of workforce that a humans
will need to compete with Roberts and,
uh,
artificial intelligence in a perspective of some professions.
Right?
So what would you recommend for,
for example,
now what,
what machine,
what we should invest to learn now to be competitive in,
in 10 years?
Yeah.
It's funny cause we,
that's exactly what we were talking with a group of people actually a few months
ago.
So what are things that will be difficult,
very difficult for humans to be replaced?
People the create the two.
That's usually the creative portions of it,
the creative arts,
the creative environment.
But,
um,
so,
so there's how,
how do you see the thing is these,
even though we can make an impact,
we can increase the amount of jobs the human can,
can,
can take.
It's still,
it's not enough to,
to for the whole market,
uh,
infrastructure.
Uh,
and Doug said this is very different.
For example,
in the beginning of the century,
people thought then that's a revolution.
We'll keep everybody away from jobs.
And we found obviously it wasn't true.
People just be adapted and they used their skill somewhere else.
Now the thing here is if we're talking about creating new species that are
substantially smarter than humans and they can do so many things,
I said,
if you'll be very,
very difficult than a hundred years,
if you can distinguish between a human with a robot and a person,
the more we advance,
it's become very difficult.
So how do you compete with that?
I mean,
it's still with,
we haven't solved these questions are very valid question.
And,
and obviously if we know the answer,
we'll start putting all the resources to,
to,
to creating the solid infrastructure is from today.
So we can actually have a balance and you'll be able to minimize that,
that these impacts.
That's,
yeah.
Very good question.
Thanks.
Won't behind you.
I can still write better poems than machines.
So I think I got,
I know exactly,
exactly.
Hi there.
I have a question about this space exploring and the,
the technology that we use in that.
So we have these shadows that are already in the,
uh,
I don't know all the,
the end of the solar system and of course the operating system and the machines
used of them.
They are of course our data.
How do we plan on the future missions to have them constantly being updated?
Do we plan on,
uh,
artificial technology that will update itself or do we plan to,
to,
to send a different models to update it on the way?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So that depends on the mission you're trying to design.
If you're designing something with the intention of going to apply and take some
pictures and come back,
probably the time period is,
it doesn't give you,
it's not really necessary,
but for longer missions,
that's definitely going to be important.
I don't know if you guys heard of the breakthrough initiative that's being put
together.
Okay.
So this is an initiative that's going to enable us to send a vehicle called a
vehicle.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a hard word,
one gram hardware powered by laser and it's going to go at a 20% of the speed of
light and it's going to go to office and jewelry,
which basically it's the closest store that we have here.
And we found that there is habitable planets in office and jury.
So habitable planets,
it's essentially a term we call about four planets that are surrounding stars.
So for life to exist,
uh,
attempt to have certain distance from there,
from the star,
if it's too close,
then the water will evaporate.
If it's too far,
it will freeze.
And um,
and also it has to be certain size if it's too small to have difficulties.
Keeping an environment.
If it's too big,
it will trap poisonous environment.
So it's very unique thing that we need to have to have life.
Obviously there's billions of galaxies,
so possibilities are endless,
but for machines that are going to send that will take long,
long time,
then definitely it will be important to start implementing some of the elements
you're mentioning.
It will be difficult.
Um,
uh,
sending,
distractions from Earth cause it will takes such a long time to reach them and
by the time you reach them as priority already obsolete.
So how do you develop something where the system itself can,
can,
can update.
So I think that that's a very important turning point.
When can artificial intelligence make changes to itself and adapt and change the
algorithm based and what's learning?
Now we're talking about complete paradigm shift here,
but it will be very important for long term missions.
I think we're unfortunately out of time folks.
I know we have to close it out.
So what I will say is perhaps,
uh,
thank you very much doctor Omar
[inaudible] appreciate it.